a major winter storm has slammed into
the u.s east coast with high winds and
heavy snow
severe weather alerts were issued across
a region of around 70 million people
residents are being urged to stay
indoors and avoid unnecessary travel
yeah just
lost power about two hours ago
now
[Music]
but right now it's you're getting a few
inches an hour three inches at least
coming every hour it's getting heavy a
little wetter than i thought too it's
supposed to be light fluffy but it's a
little wet and heavy
almost zero visibility when you're
driving
um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
is
and cape cod in massachusetts is one of
the worst hit places with 100 of
customers in the town of provincetown
losing power on saturday and from there
i'm joined by meteorologist matthew
capucci uh matthew at least 10 states
apparently have been affected by this
storm that's a fifth of the entire
united states what's the situation like
now
it was definitely a pretty impressive
storm you know we had about 10 million
people who saw a foot or more of
snowfall behind me right now you can see
about 50 to 60 centimeters on the ground
the snow just ended about two or three
hours ago but look at this we were got a
bare pavement yesterday and now all of a
sudden we have really impressive snow
totals that fence over there is roughly
about as tall as me
and now all of a sudden you can only see
about half of it you can just see how
deep that snow is now one of the
interesting elements we talked about how
this is a bomb cyclone indeed it is but
what does that mean well when you have a
strong low pressure system it sucks air
in and evacuates it out the top this
thing intensified so quickly that its
central pressure just plummeted it was
like a vacuum cleaner so it went from
barely anything a blip on weather maps
to a hurricane force low in just 24
hours time almost doubling the pace of
rapid strengthening you need to get that
bomb cyclone status well that's pretty
impressive and this blizzard is expected
to keep the east coast in its grip from
what we hear well into sunday do the
authorities you feel have the situation
under control
well the good news right now the storm
is actually pulling away towards the
canadian maritime so no more blizzard
for us but now it's kind of round two of
the inclement weather because
temperatures are dropping quite a bit a
lot of folks as you mentioned don't have
power 100 to provincetown without power
about 20 of cape cod as a whole without
power so now temperatures are about
minus five to minus 10 degrees celsius
that's dangerous for the elderly
vulnerable populations who don't have
heat and so while officials are trying i
haven't really been impressed by even
road plowing effort we had snowfall
rates about 10 centimeters per hour
earlier on that's something that no road
crew can handle so my street for example
still hasn't been plowed that atop of
cold temperatures dangerous for people
who don't have the necessary precautions
in place
yeah i can imagine and listen we're just
starting 2022. but if we look back on
2021 in the states the weather stories
the deadly colds in texas california
burning kentucky tornadoes
this year
is there you know seems to be starting
off on on a negative foot again is there
some sort of relationship to this
pattern to global warming
that's a really good question now the
northeast does see these storms quite a
bit once or twice every winter ones of
this magnitude are pretty rare now
overall thanks to human induced climate
change we're actually seeing less snow
in general because obviously it's a
little bit warmer so it's tougher to get
snow but the cool thing is because it's
a little warmer we're adding more
moisture to the air so for occasions
where we'd already be below freezing now
there's just that much extra moisture to
work with so we actually get bigger
snows during the high-end events so to
recap overall less snow but when we do
get snowstorms once in a while they tend
to be a little bigger than they
otherwise would be boston actually set
their record for snowiest january day
ever observed with records dating back
the 1800s so this really was a high-end
event
okay that's meteorologist matthew
capucci
showing us the snowstorm in cape cod
massachusetts thanks so much
thank you
you